[Musik]
diesen titel überlegt morgens schon was
sie kochen und essen will charlotte
würdig ist gerade trotz corona einen
halbmarathon gelaufen
patricia platil gibt zu dass sie im
moment einfach mehr alkohol trinkt als
sonst unser gast uschi glas ist
überzeugt wer sich nicht bewegt wird und
ausgeglichen so meiner du bist mir
unheimlich leid maradona ich verstehe es
nicht
ich weiß ich muss dazu sagen ich hab
auch schon ein essen gedacht bevor kann
losgehen
aber ich habe wirklich den eindruck dass
das nicht teil einer ersatzbefriedigung
ist gebe ich unumwunden zu und wenn ich
dann diese schönen bilder sehe bei
instagram dann frage ich mich was es in
meinem leben schief gelaufen doch habe
ich irgendwie mehr bücher gelesen noch
habe ich jetzt eine gesündere ernährung
im gegenteil
und ich brauche gerade geradezu
kohlenhydrate also erstens war das für
mich aber ein ziel damit mein kopf klar
bleibt nicht möchte laufen gehen ich
setze mir jetzt ein ziel es ist ein
halbmarathon das wirst du schaffen und
sechs bis sieben wochen und das ziehst
du jetzt durch das ist ein ziel das kann
mir kein politiker da draußen nehmen das
kann mir niemand nehmen
das ist mein ziel woraufhin ich in
arbeit in mein erfolgserlebnis meine
indochina die einem gut tun so im
endeffekt und zweitens und das ist auch
immer das was ich ganz aufhöre wenn ich
wenn ich vom sport erzähle ja ich bin
aber trinkt aber gerne oder ich esse
gerne kohlenhydrate leicht doch auch ja
klar aber ich muss sich etwas vornehmen
wenn man darf nicht übrigens wir reden
jeden tag mein mann rum sagt was kochen
und inhalt abend und es ist dann
tatsächlich schon so eine freude erstmal
darüber nachzudenken wenn ich was könnte
man den kochen ja was haben den gestern
gegessen also tatsächlich ist es so
genau so wie ich sage ich muss zum
beispiel ich muss bewegung haben ich
kann zum beispiel nicht lernen so etwas
aufnehmen wenn ich still sitzen das
heißt ich habe immer in bewegung gelernt
meine texte man alles und deswegen ist
für mich bewegung einfach wichtig und es
macht mich auch zufrieden wenn ich eine
schenkung erreicht habe würde wünschte
das wäre bei mir so wie er das beide
beschreibt also dass ich freude daran
hat
das essen zu planen gegen vielleicht
genug mit seinen kindern schon natürlich
ganz kurz ein viertel zeigen von einer
prominenten familie und zwar hier heidi
klum hat sich nämlich auch ein bisschen
was sie gern zwischendurch also die hat
sich gar nichts gegönnt so sehe ich
nicht mal so sehe ich nicht mal ohne
jegliche mahlzeit in meinem bauch
außerdem hatte doch den bauernhof
gesprächs ist die heidi klum erst mal
die grundsatzfrage welche links rainer
klump das soll natürlich jetzt natürlich
sagen aber ich glaube wenn aber so sagt
man sich jetzt schon über spritzen
realität hat das publikum damit will die
uns auch ja sagen guck mal das ist halt
so dass zur quarantäne bäuchlein was
auch immer gerade in diesen zeiten so
geht es mir zumindest ich habe ich
brauche gar nicht mehr regeln ich habe
das gefühl ich habe so viel zu tun den
ganzen tag regeln die ich jetzt einheit
muss ich möchte überhaupt nicht habe zum
beispiel nicht das bedürfnis ich
wünschte es wäre so es würde mir gut und
definitiv aber ich habe nicht das
bedürfnis mich dann am ende des tages zu
bewegen oder mir ein ziel zu setzen oder
mehr in essensplan zu machen ich möchte
dann wirklich kann ich deswegen auch
über eine ansage gar nicht trinke mehr
ist und mir reichen ein tuch über die
dauer weile und dann und dann möchte ich
auch mal dann möchte ich eine winzige
party die man sonst nicht haben kann
habe ich dann irgendwie mit einem glas
wein und können mir dass ich möchte dann
auf genug geht mit einer banane es gibt
hier einen ballon tag
ich habe also ich habe also es gibt ja
im endeffekt das ist ja auch so dass man
sagen kann man kann sich ja das gläschen
wein oder zwei drei vier fünf was auch
immer oder einem wissen was ein gutes zu
essen aber für mich ist es nur die die
balance
das gegengewicht zu den und dann geht es
mir einfach in dem moment besser
[Musik]